let's go 5 if you're new again you're
guessing it's by default it will just do
a 5-minute standard unrated game and if
you want something else just be specific
we could do whatever up to 5 minutes
being the slowest up to 5 minutes being
the slowest no increment there so this
look at my mouse bam take like this it's
not the UH I still thinks oh look at my
mouse is a wonderful start
oh man I just earned I was getting ready
to brag look at my mouth yeah did I
really want to do that for that oh yeah
that was planned that was a planner
right there alright so what do you do
when your mouse lip oh man oh we do back
up here yeah
ah how to improvise here when there's a
pawn on f6 and your knight looks stupid
well
uh what up in here
d5 I really don't like that they'll
probably be a sack and my truck and I
e-file opens up Bishop here f4 then what
maybe that's not so bad I can give that
a shot
or maybe Knight a 7 g6 and then here
let's try that what a good start
what a wonderful start I wasn't gonna
start bragging about my mouse but for
those of you that are not informed about
what I'm getting at I posted a link to
my facebook not too long ago saying
Apollo I was apologizing to my mouse for
blaming it for all the mouse slips when
really it was a little thing called
mouse acceleration that I was
experiencing for over a year since
switching to a Mac I'm running off a
MacBook Pro right now uh ok that night
is stuck isn't he
let's play here first pin this pawn
pretty bad f4 so anyhow this this little
thing that I'm doing right now I'm
moving like my mouse as fast as I can in
before when I was doing that with the
most acceleration on it would actually
fly across my whole computer screen but
not now it goes where I actually want it
so
it's still a little bit it drags a
little bit slow when I have the pieces
there so I got to do this tonight I
think I should be alright um here's the
other thing let me just lock down an F
for no no no no F for isn't even
threatened why should I lock down on it
what should I do
my LightSquared Bishop wants to play so
let's get playing the King goes here
then I'll do maybe g5 only when this can
maybe be a threat but lets me let me
negate my opponents idea so alright
let's go here the LightSquared bishop
back up
and well already mmm I think I really
know you know I don't like this move you
know why it stops f-for but it allows
the Queen to make use of this and I
might want to play King f7 rook h8
so let's not do that
Oh what I could do is grab here but then
the rook comes over and gets this but
what if I take first that's a different
story isn't it
we're right no what is the plan here the
big bad plan is going to be I really
want to play here and bring my rook over
or should I just do this and with the
pawn push oh no no he gun watch out for
that tricky tricky night he was ready to
kill me ah maybe I should play here two
reasons to do it now this was my first
thought but I thought okay so and I
chased the rook here probably wants to
go there maybe but it's watching over a
six two reasons maybe I should go with
that five pinpoint this but this guy is
a very good defender or what I could try
to do is f5 with the intention of maybe
squashing this guy and then being even
going forward again mmm it's a thought
isn't it I think I like that idea
i weakened my Kings side a bit but I
don't know that these guys can really
get at me I'm gonna give this a shot I'm
gonna give it a whirl
alrighty what is this clean up to no
good here she's up to no good
this guy's gonna fall isn't he my
bishops getting here I got to do this
and I here is the situation I'm going to
be confronted with right now the queen
is gonna give a check and I have to
bring my queen over here otherwise if I
move my king there's like this move and
kind of dead and that's what's being
threatened right now I think I have to
come over here
control this f4 square and also fight
back I need to fight back and ah I'm
getting forked and everything now I'm
dropping this pawn could these bishops
do something good here I might be able
to maybe get at this pawn let me take
here first and then play my Bishop here
I just want an exchange and maybe get it
this pawn or something oh this nights
gonna kill me
he's gonna be a killer isn't he I don't
know if I really want to go for this
pawn push idea I better come up with
something quick
how about pawn push pawn push this seems
to work yeah let me just take this night
is a bit homeless if Queen takes pawn I
think it's close to being made or
something it's not too far from being me
f2 and this idea right here with the
pawn push is gonna be brutal these
bishops are sitting pretty proud right
now but I think I kind of got lucky
there to get this kind of position I
dropped that pond now getting rid of my
rook
I'm gonna take that and do a pond push
it takes it'll probably be no no won't
really be me well it like uh I should
probably just go here I should have done
that removal sooner
cuz this nights uh out of squares isn't
he I could do it right now ah move
sooner was better wouldn't have been
don't have any time well you know what
I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get my queen here and then
here
could this squared be defended
I'm just threatening to a queen right
now let's point out the obvious first
I'm just threatening a queen that has to
be defended the pawn can't push and now
after this this is a deadly deflection
but there's a deadly fork hang on
I can't it be easier just can't be
easier I'm gonna go here 20 seconds I
think I still have this with just like a
clean here eventually and then here this
is an this Bishop is not going to be
able to come back to defend and now if
Queen takes Queen I just promote to a
queen with me alright I don't have to
recapture
um that's me all right that was I don't
think there was a good solution at that
point Wow
not without a fight down upon there
let's go back
all right good game let's flip this
hangout let's go back and let's flip and
let's see where either one of us could
have improved what is the first thing
that kind of jumps out to me
well that move don't do f6 okay so
that's unfortunate I don't know about
taking my night cuz uh what are you
doing you're building my center in this
guy I'm not so sure he has a wonderful
future he ended up being a bit of a bug
to me but I would I would hold off on
capturing on c6 I don't think it's a
good a good choice to be going with that
I don't have to worry about Knight b5
stuff at all I might do this just to
stop Knight b5 stuff so if you if you
really wanted to let's say take on c6
maybe hold off make me do something like
a six first a six is played to watch out
for b5 in expand with b5 but if you hold
off a move and let's say bring out your
light square bishop or your dark square
bishop and after I play a six then take
then this a six advance kind of is
pointless doesn't really serve as good
of a role
so maybe just facilitate your
development prior to this type of
capture go with the bishop out one of
these two I really I really don't know
but this this capture so early I don't I
really don't know about it and yeah I
don't know this I didn't want to play
off six but anything further okay well
here's the other thing
in order for white to really get an
advantage you have to get this F pawn
where
in some way and I really wasn't fearful
of a whole lot if you're if you're not
getting your f-pawn involved so don't
don't obstruct this guy on the white
side of an open Sicilian you have to in
most cases get your F pawn and upon
working together so if you really want
to place your bishop here maybe look to
first play f4 and only then Bishop f3
but I think getting that if there's one
pawn to get involved it's going to be
that F pawn okay you gave up the
LightSquared Bishop yeah I don't I don't
know that those are the main points I
think I stand better here just the
bishop pair I have a nice Center this
Bishop and just kind of biting at that
b5 pound there's not a convenient way to
crack at it you ended up winning upon I
shouldn't have allowed that before was a
bit interesting maybe I should have done
something different after Bishop c4 here
instead of f5 I I didn't see the Queen
coming out how about instead of f5 maybe
no no if I go here I'm dropping this
pond so Queen they're pointing out to be
a bit annoying right here pressure on
the bishop both bishops indirectly that
LightScribe wood bishop c6 I didn't
really want to move this for two reasons
d5 and also my bishop on a6 is kind of
shut out so had some pressure on me on
the Queen side there but I think just
even getting into this position is not
really a good idea and just looking to
kind of drawn back to f4 at this point
and even earlier the earliest point
being the decision to grab the knight as
early as you did all right